[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh brandel shambly golf channel analyst
joining us on the program what do you
think of that logic there we have a keg
white castle and uh i take my chances
you just made me hungry who doesn't like
white castle i mean normally i i've
i've had them at 2 30 in the morning
i've actually never had them at dinner
time so i assume they're pretty darn
good then too
i don't think anybody's ever had white
castles before like 10 o'clock at night
it always feels like right you know
right i can remember
i can remember having bacon
cheeseburgers at 2 30 in college from
jack in the box never eaten it since
but it was the best damn meal i ever had
in my life and
i mean i'm probably just like 2 000
calories in the thing but man they were
good
anybody ever have any strange eating
habits on the course when you played
what they had in their bag
well there used to be a fella that well
you know you know who mark lie is he
still still does radio or whatever but
you know he uh he was a diabetic so he
had to eat
constantly when when he played and this
was back before there were power bars or
anything like that so
he would have you know all kinds of
things wrapped up in tin foil and he'd
be unwrapping them
pretty much every hole so you'd have to
just back away and go you know what what
are you doing this is like an
all-day buffet trot you know um
that was about it i can't remember any
odd eating habits on the golf course
but there are guys who snuck in liquor
when they played
oh i i i know a few players that uh
that had you know they they were all
always had a coke can with them
and you know there were i know i know a
few players that that one
uh you know probably past the legal
limit
um you know they could play pretty good
they were they were like you you know
you said you could handle your beer they
i know a few players that can handle
there but is this to calm your nerves
well one one player in particular who's
an absolute legend
um he was i'm not gonna name him but he
was in a playoff once with jack nicklaus
and and he ducked into the bathroom okay
and two or three times during this
playoff and
and then you know you know they finally
played on and i believe john
well there you go
i didn't say and look it's not the last
name you think okay
so uh he prevailed boy you can keep a
secret randall
yeah right yeah that's so bad isn't it i
forgot nobody else is listening right
no no no no we're not even we're not
even back on the
air right now right that's what i
thought yeah we're always meant to act
like we're just sitting around talking
right
yeah yeah and uh we welcome you back to
the dan patrick show no no no
no don't do that so anyway afterwards
jax went up to
you know the guy who's won buddy right
he said i'm worried
that he's he's that he's drinking and my
buddy
he started laughing he was like jack
he'd never stop
drinking but he was a terrific fellow
and a hell of a player and uh yeah he
had a few pops from time to time
all right the uh bryson de shambo bet
that i have
you can either take him to win or
he misses the cut but the
you you get your straight up bet let's
say you put a thousand dollars on it
to win you get 10 000 if he misses the
cut
which one would you take oh i'd go for
the win
i i don't i i can't i can't even come up
with any scenario where he's
he's not a factor in this event you know
um
if he drives it any seamless like he did
at the us open and by all accounts he's
20 30 yards longer than he was then
which is preposterous
um you know he's going to be chipping to
so many of these greens he's going to be
hitting wedges to the par fives and
he's a much much better putter than he
was
you know last year at this time he's
10th he was 10th
he was 10th in 2020 and and strokes game
putting
with that lane so i'd go for the win i i
don't see anybody getting
that ten thousand dollars dan do you
think it's his to lose
uh yes actually that's a good question
um yes i i do you know did you hear
tiger yesterday in the media center he
said tiger
said of bryson that he's doing things
that nobody has ever done in the history
of the game
i mean that that would be like that'd be
like shakespeare saying another writer
could really turn a phrase
what it what's the downside any downside
to bryson duchambeau
this style this philosophy i i would
have said
you know he's he's he likes to swing
into out on it
and i would have said historically
players who swing into out have trouble
off of the side hill lies
at augusta national so the great players
are cutting it off those sort of hook
lies
they're picking it and cutting it
getting it up in the air but ridiculous
yeah like like jack and tiger and even
you know jordan spieth
is the perfect example and and justin
thomas
is the perfect example of somebody who
could do that but
bryson hits it past all those spots
where that would be an issue like miles
past it like he
he could hit it 30 40 yards past dustin
johnson and brooks kept
like i've never seen anything like that
but how do you explain that because
every weekend golfer is swinging out of
their shoes now
brandel yeah how do you get length
and then how do you add even more length
to it when you're a professional
yeah the thing is there was there was so
much room for added distance in this
game you think about it
i've made this analogy but years ago you
know you tune in you watch nolan ryan
and you know they were they were kind of
guessing but they're like he's throwing
at 105 miles an hour
and you could assume that nobody else in
the in the world could throw a baseball
harder than that
but you tuned into a golf tournament you
see tiger woods hitting the shot and
he's swinging 124 miles an hour
well there are scores of people that
could swing way faster
than that scores in the game long drive
guys
what bryson did was he studied the long
drive guys
and he tapped into their movements okay
because
there was clearly room to swing the club
20 miles an hour faster amongst the best
professional golfers but the
but everybody dismissed the long drive
guys as freaks
or they couldn't play golf but what
bryson did was he watched the long drive
guys
really studied it from a biomechanic
standpoint their movements
and incorporated those movements but
then this was the
coup de grace really he added elements
of the straightest hitters of all time
because they do very specific things
just like long drive guys do and then he
meshed those two
and that's the holy grail and that's why
you know normally when when guys get
paired with tiger or phil
you see them walking down the fairway
and they're always turned looking at
tiger or phil and tiger phil are never
looking at them
and they're just kind of walking ahead
when you see tiger or phil get paired
with bryson
bryson's walking down the fairway tiger
and phil are turned looking at bryson
and trying to soak up everything that
this guy knows
because clearly he's tapped into
something that nobody else has tapped
into in the game of golf
professional game ago i'm wondering
though bryson you know how
augusta the masters they control
everything do they get to the point
where they say you have to have a golf
ball
that is to our specifications to play
this
course but i just worry about courses
becoming antiquated because of
you know equipment the golf ball you
know the golfer i understand but the
equipment
and the golf ball is changing the sport
could you see the masters
in five years from now when how many
golfers are going to try to incorporate
what bryson duchamp is doing whether
they do it correctly or not
and you know those par fives some of
those aren't meant to be
had in two or at least you don't have a
wedge in there
and that's what's going to happen here
listen not five years five months from
now they might be playing
gutta percha and hickory when they come
back
because i mean what bryson is on the
cusp of doing this week what he could
very well do
is and and i've argued against people
who say that the ball should be rolled
back because
the same things still matter in the game
strategy long drive i mean
long irons all those things yeah but
what bryson could do was
literally
obliterate the integrity of this design
i mean drive and chip to greens and
drive wedges to par fives i've never
thought the argument was really
on that sort of solid foundation until
bryson came along so what are you gonna
do
if you if you run this event and
obviously the usga and the rna governing
bodies they have
many many different factors to consider
but the masters is in a position where
they can just unilaterally say
okay we're going to have a tournament
ball yeah and scale things back a bit
yeah but then you know the if you scale
it back to where bryson is the one
who is is struggling to get on these par
fives and two
nobody else in the game could get on
these par fives and two like nobody else
so then it's not very interesting so
it's it's what do you do
you know how do you how do you combat
this
where the the the golf is still
compelling because right now
i think we can all agree the masters has
a pretty good history of producing
compelling events
with the formula they have we're talking
to bryce
bryson brandel chamblee you wish i was
saying bryce industries
how far would he out drive you at your
best when you were playing without drive
me by
a hundred yards you know if i pop one
now if i really pop one
i might get a 290 but more you know
right around there he's gonna hit he's
he carried it 362 the other day
on the range one swing carried at 362.
that's going to roll 400. i know that's
why i said
to start the show he'll hit drives of
400 yards
at augusta and now i know it's a little
wet there conditions
yeah but um how's it going to look in
sound tomorrow you know if you you can
probably find it online if you haven't
already seen it but you can find him
hitting this shot
uh two days ago on the range and it
i mean it sounded like a canon it really
did i mean it really did i i
replayed it you know i don't even know i
probably watched it like 50 times
and i couldn't believe the sound of it
and you know he backed away and you
could hear the person videotaping it
saying was that 200
meaning the ball speed was at 200 he has
a machine there it measures it instantly
and he was like oh yeah
201 and i mean it doesn't
it like i can remember i honestly i can
remember hitting balls next to tiger
woods at the 2000 uso but tiger played
all right in that event
yeah okay now on tuesday i'm hitting
balls next to him
he's right behind me hitting balls and
i'm grinding away you know i'm not
paying attention to tiger
you know i'm dumb enough to think i you
know i can get a chance or whatever
my buddy is there watching me and he
says hey stop
hey and i said what he goes if you don't
turn around and watch what's happening
behind you you will have missed the
greatest show ever
this is tuesday so i turn around and i
watch him you know and the sound of it
right and the flight of it and the power
and the grace
you know i just never heard anything
like that i watched him for like 20 30
minutes completely
forgot what i was doing then he walked
away and then the next
shot i hit i swear it sounded like i hit
a wiffle ball
and it and it looked like i hit a wiffle
ball and i was like he just
i'm i feel impotent you know it's like
what am i even
what am i even doing why did i watch
that
i don't that's like following you know i
remember reading once where billy
crystal said he thought he was a really
funny guy and he got invited to go to
this gig
right he's slaying it everywhere and
he's standing in the wings and he's
listening to this guy on the stage and
he's like
this is the funniest human being i've
ever heard i suck
i am not funny that guy's funny and he
had to follow robin williams yeah
and he was like you know you you what
are you going to do and it's like i
watched tiger and i thought
we're not even playing the same game i
think he beat me by 35 shots that week
tiger's chances this week or what
not great you know top 10
13 hey listen i've learned on your show
to never say never okay
[Laughter]
you did learn the hard way yeah he tiger
just did that to me yes he did
uh and it was great to see i did
occasionally i don't know if i did on
your show
add the caveat that i hope i'm wrong and
if anybody could prove me wrong was
tiger and he certainly
did uh you know the masters has a way of
providing hail mary's to great stars you
know jack had one ben crenshaw had maybe
the greatest hail mary i've ever seen in
golf
um tiger had a bit of a one last year
but he was playing fine golf coming in
here so
you could kind of sense it uh he's
hitting it you know he's he's
the last time he was out dan at zozo it
sure would
uh his clubhead speed had dropped to 113
miles an hour that's tour
average and and he's not really picked
up any accuracy to sort of offset that
decay in his clubhead speed so
you know again there's i don't know
you'd know this so like great athletes
it's really hard to point at the part
where they are not physically capable of
doing
what they're imminently capable of doing
mentally and it's tiger's not there yet
but you know it happens like
incrementally
and you know he's he's lost a little
club head speed from last year
he still had pop last year you know he
drove it past
female last year on the 17th hole coming
in
and and it surprised tiger and
afterwards he said you know i ramped up
my club head speed so maybe that
adrenaline rush happens this week but
he's going to need that club head speed
as wet as it is do you think last year's
masters
was the last one for tiger i am not
going to say that dad i i'm not as dumb
as you think i am dan
i mean i'm close i'm really close but
i'm not that dumb
uh he's at 82. he's going to get another
one
great to talk to you we'll be watching
uh love uh live for the masters
tell uh rich and company that we said
hello and uh thanks for joining us again
randall i'll do it don't share
our secret that we're talking no don't
drink it okay all right that's just
between you and me yes indeed talk to
you later
brandel's on site at augusta national
this week contributing to the network's
golf central live from the masters
coverage
throughout the week the great rich
lerner is your host coverage can be seen
prior to and immediately following live
tournament coverage thursday
through sunday